call of duty zombies call of duty
zombies
from its humble beginnings in 2008's
world at war this
unlockable game mode took the cod world
by storm and
in its wake gave us hundreds of hours of
zombie killing greatness
we all have stories about staying up
late and slaying the undead until dawn
but how how did this nearly scrap game
mode win the hearts of millions of
players who still play to this day
let's talk about it here are 7 reasons
why call of duty zombies
is great if you like call of duty
zombies too drop a like and subscribe we
talk about call of duty
all the time from the very beginning
there were wonder weapons the special
guns and gear created by powers
not of this world their mission to take
down the undead and the fastest and
flashiest way possible
they're splattered all over the place
now
you filthy dogs beginning with the ray
gun of course more and more wonder
weapons have been introduced over the
years
and have evolved into multi-purpose
killing machines that could blast the
undead
and help you with an easter egg they
aren't all great
a part of the fun involves chasing
around the mystery box and spending your
hard-earned zombie bucks on a gamble
when you didn't want them you got them
when you needed them
they were nowhere to be found but when
you finally did get one your squad was
green with envy
the ray gun will always be my favorite
i'll never forget the first time i got
it from the box and how i immediately
freaked out when i saw how it looked
sounded and how easily it killed zombies
what about you
what's your favorite i ask you
who doesn't love the pack-a-punch
machine got a great gun and want to make
it better
pack-a-punch it got a handgun from the
mystery box
pack-a-punch it got your hands on the
new wonder weapon
pack it
this bowling score machine from the
1950s is your best friend
the pack-a-punch machine was introduced
in the dare rhys map
and since then has been a staple in the
zombies universe for a premium fee of 5
000 zombie bucks
you can increase your gun's power and
ammo capacity while obtaining a sweet
but cursed
paint job using the powers of element
115 the pack-a-punch machine not only
kicks your gun into overdrive but can
change some of its attributes
for example in some games like black ops
1 you can change the fire rate of the
m16 from a 3 round burst to full
auto with noob tubes and like i
mentioned it can pack a single handgun
firing regular bullets
to a dual wielding menace that fires
grenade rounds
not so much anymore but he used to
bottom line a zombie's map without a
pack of punch machine
is simply incomplete
with every annual release of call of
duty we'd see the same setup
campaign and online multiplayer the
bread and butter of call of duty games
but outside of the dlc multiplayer maps
there wasn't much else in terms of
variety
enter zombies mode it was a great way to
break up those long gaming nights
after some sweaty matches of multiplayer
you can swap over to zombies and take
out your kd frustrations on the undead
my friends and i would go back and forth
between game modes until someone would
finally call alright last one for me
it was only then when i realized it was
actually 4 a.m
oh where does the time go
troy loves to hide secrets in zombies
mode and we love to find them
everything from music to intel nearly
every map is brimming with secrets
why are they gonna put a music easter
egg in every map now
who else goes around every new map and
mashing the interact button like it's
resident evil
sniffing around and hoping to unlock
something before your friends do
sometimes they were just for fun but
other times these secrets would reveal
little parts of the greater story
everything was always so shrouded in
mystery and we'd lived for it
nowadays even with a more streamlined
story intel can be found all over the
place
you get radio conversations and side
stories about your team and their
findings
best of all you can re-listen to them
anytime
speaking of stories it's mind-blowing to
think that
zombies started out as a simple survival
mode with absolutely no story
when world at war launched in 2008 the
vanilla release didn't even have voices
for your character
soon enough new maps characters and the
beginning of a grand story arc formed
around this little game mode
if you've played zombies for a while you
know how tangled the tales could get
i myself didn't play black ops 3 so when
i picked it back up with black ops 4
i was like what the [ __ ] happened here i
was pretty confused but
i wasn't alone there are so many
explainer videos on youtube that it
makes my head spin
people ate this stuff up and that's
because treyarch does
not skimp out when it comes to
storytelling some might even say they go
overboard in this department
but it doesn't matter because even if
you don't follow the story
the core gameplay of zombies will always
shine through
currently we're in a place where the
zombie story is a little more at ease
but it's slowly building to something
bigger i can feel it
[Music]
ah perks cracking a cold one to unlock a
superpower
just can't be beat over the years there
have been several perk machines
each offering a fun and unique way to
turn you into a zombie killing machine
there are the classic perks like
juggernog and speed cola and more were
introduced that were helpful
in unexpected ways perks like death
perception that lets you see
enemies through walls or electric bursts
which zaps enemies around you while you
reload
in some maps you were limited to only
four
but today you can have as many as you
want and they can each be leveled up
multiple times for other effects some of
these effects are actually old perks you
may remember
while perks are a necessity for higher
rounds of zombies they're also just sort
of fun to collect
so buy them all and watch as your player
becomes an absolute
tank i already mentioned secrets but
this
is the big stuff easter eggs and call of
duty are the crown jewel of the entire
mode
it's puzzle solving storytelling boss
fighting and dumb luck
rolled all into one it's also the
fastest way to lose track of time
hours will go by as you try to solve
these especially if you're on your own
or without a guide
these easter eggs can push your zombie
survival skills to their limits
but the payoff is always worth it even
if you don't pay attention to the story
these are what help elevate zombies from
a survival mode to the thrilling and
involved story that it is today
personally speaking i was already in
love with the core mode from day one
but when they started adding all these
easter eggs in i knew the mode was here
to stay
eventually the series would feature
detailed stories in the style of
animated stills
but for some of the bigger moments
treyarch produced full cinematics that
were
unforgettable
now more than ever call of duty zombies
can't be stopped
its story is vast and its gameplay is as
addictive as ever
there's also a nice flow of content with
new maps and wonder weapons and stories
added in every season
from the beginning people have wanted
more and more zombies
even begging for a dedicated zombies
game that would stand alone from the
black
ops titles only time will tell if we
ever see that until then
share your love for zombies in the
comments and drop a like if you enjoyed
this list
alright that'll do it for me i'm gonna
go play some zombies
you